ومشاهدينا نتابع معكم اذا هذه الصور لاثار
القصف حيث يسقط صاروخ على ما يبدو في هذه
الصوره في مستوطنه اشكول هذه الصواريخ
التي اطلقت من غزه حيث سقط هذا الصاروخ
كما نشاهد الان في هذه المنطقه في مستوطنه
ايشكو ياتي هذا في سياق التصعيد الكبير
والمتواصل ومتصاعد ايضا بين الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبين الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه العربيه تؤكد ان كما نشاهد الخبر
العاجل ان هناك غارات اسرائيليه على مناطق
شمالي قطاع غزه وقد قام ايضا الجيش
الاسرائيلي باعتراض القبه الحديديه او
اعلن اعتراض القبه الحديديه لعده صواريخ
اطلقت من غزه باتجاه
المستوطنات المحاذيه للقطاع وباتجاه القدس
ايضا قبل ذلك ايضا مشاهدينا اسرائيل اعلنت
تجميد محادثات التهدئه مع الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في وقت تتواصل المواجهات لليوم
الرابع ونذكر ايضا مشاهدينا بان الصحه
الفلسطينيه اعلنت حتى الان او كشفت عن
ارتفاع حصيله القتلى في القصف الاسرائيلي
على قطاع غزه الى واحد وثلاثين فلسطينيا
من بينهم سته اطفال لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات